how's it going red my name is really bad
and welcome to Sims today
Sunset Valley based on its in Swedish
Quan shopping fun million spec Wow
alright let's let's do this
this game was so highly suggest said I
want to make at least one video ok cuz
you know I played Sims 2 and it was
jolly good times I remember not that
much of it but here we are
what was it John shopping or no it was
crunch Epping all these Swedish people
will get that but if you are Swedish you
probably wouldn't laugh anyway alright
let's create artisan empanada comment in
this derp and me haha sorry dad but
dragon the music Matt digging the music
alright let's let's make him beautiful
what is his name huh I let's go with
error as spawns big ball I
[Music]
all right there we go there's possible
snow did it didn't didn't know it's
gonna be pretty good
oh oh okay the vacant mat is in sight
all right all right taking this game so
far it's [ __ ] awesome
all right which hair should we get yeah
would you perhaps we're looking into
something emo
no this is not my hair cut my head is
not like it's kinda look like no offense
but Ian from Smosh fat fat Ian from hood
not okay what can i browse do we have
here oh no no no no what happened you
were so beautiful yeah yeah yeah oh we
can choose Kalle I'm gonna go with my
own color scheme you never seen a green
unibrow before
well you ain't live man you ain't live
all right let's give him a little
mustache beautiful so beautiful I don't
even know what it begin
we got to change the color on that thing
Alex set a ginger mix of ginger and all
righty nice more beautiful ice nose Marv
Marv yet no no I wanted those lips all
right let me just one second let me get
back to hair and I want to change the
hair color I think
did I miss something here and then Oh
let's give him everything more than fun
oh man I should be like a plastic
surgeon makeup no yes so gorgeous what
is this let's give him raccoon eyes
[Music]
funny thing is he actually look better
than a lot of Garten I'm just kidding
today to date oh really
and there there there it and to top it
off yeah
[Music]
like a mix of hips and email and just I
believe oh oh no all right that actually
works I don't take some ways unibrow I
don't want that that one is very yeah
and we are no don't randomize his face
from agency let's make another member
actually the really quick yes see if we
can change even more let's make a woman
in the house and then we're done with
this
now the question oh my god kill her nose
[ __ ] Boosh I'm a girl
alright let's make it a little thinner
no uh-uh no is this no
[Music]
she likes that oh that's a bat why why
can you change these things okay so
they're not married pretty much Jennifer
Lopez all right
ha that's not Venice oh man this is
gonna be great I can just tell already
[Music]
all right I got a pic way to live I
guess we can't afford the nice areas why
not this house with furniture buy it
it's ours
oh no the house II bought has been don't
give a [ __ ]
oh no what the hell [ __ ] did I buy what
is his name
irresponsible
it's possible dick was with the Charter
in
[Music]
[ __ ] are they so happy about that ass
how do i what ha ha ha what are you
[ __ ] going hey well she's not very
athletic she looks like a psycho killer
I don't know if I trust this to people
of mr. Shack oh you do when stop running
around Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
Jennifer Jennifer Lopez is [ __ ]
obviously great characters I got on my
sense
I went ha ha all right let's let's give
them some activities Lopez needs to get
a job but before anything else I want a
[ __ ] pool you to fish you [ __ ]
serious wait he's gonna fish what the
[ __ ] are you doing
[Laughter]
yes yes this makes sense if she can
catch her she wearing sunglasses
Jennifer Lopez where did you get those
why is there a problem with the pool all
right mr. Sherr it's the only one that
rocks in this game what is he doing show
you rule all right mr. Scheck go and
make breakfast no you can't do that well
go over here mr. Sherr love his face
when he looks up stares into your soul
what is it mr. sherry well I got this
mess i buy this [ __ ] house for what
is this Delbert it's a nice name I get a
job Jennifer but a [ __ ] are you
uh fine okay what should Jennifer be a
criminal [ __ ] yeah how does that even
work she doing
it's clearly a leakage on more than one
play it's a shadow a sharpie this
stupid-ass silly why do you keep fishing
I told you to jump in with the [ __ ] are
you is he getting laid
Wow I don't think that was possible
wait it's her name's Elbe so [ __ ] gay
all right
hello stop fishing you got a [ __ ]
girl day seriously
what all right romantic nice personality
all right more romantic you look
beautiful
my romantic flight more romantic are you
dating someone heading out her and then
be funny and then make more flatting der
der what are you doing that's disgusting
whoa I so fast wow I wish I was that
easy to entertain all right CBC go -
wait what the [ __ ]
honey this valleys [ __ ] mental
what is she doing right now what was
that why is this playing what is she
doing oh [ __ ] is she eating a window
what why I don't speak your [ __ ]
language shut up
dilution YouTube what it for mrs. sherry
just a liftin alright Oh back she said
[ __ ] odd hey lady don't he's gonna
okay so isn't go to work
where's she going now where's she going
what are you doing why go to work I
press I I don't know about this let me
know if you want more I had fun playing
at least but yeah I can phrase if you
enjoyed this guy come already and I'll
see you next episode overhead early
azimuth
go my birthday